The mean integrated standard error is the expectation values
of the square of the difference between the estimated PDF and the true PDF.
We will see this expression a lot in lesson four,
when we're validating any model in general.
This is a loss function that is used quite often, in model building.
The AMISE is the asymptotic limit of the mean integrated standard error.
It is often difficult to calculate this integral.
And we take some asymptotic value for the integral as an approximation.
Breaking the mean integrated standard error into its component,
we get some irreducible variance that comes from the data set itself.
The bias square determines the smoothness of our kernel density estimate for
different bandwidths.
The variance determines the jaggediness of the kernel density estimate for
a different bandwidths.
So the choosing the right bandwidth is a tradeoff between the Bias square and
the variance.
We will learn a lot more about these two quantities in the next lesson,
where we emphasize validation of models.